Samsung va sortir c'est nouveau Galaxy
S23 dans différentes couleurs dans les
couleurs de base on a le noir le crème
le vert le lavande personnellement moi
je préfère ce petit verre là que vous
avez sur galaxy S23 ultra d'ailleurs
dites-moi c'est votre préféré également
mais il y a également quatre couleurs
exclusives sur les S23 is 23 plus il y a
du graphite du lime en gros le gris et
le citron vert plutôt jaune citron vert
d'ailleurs et sur ultra vous avez toutes
les couleurs le graphique le live il y a
également un bleu ciel que je trouve
juste hyper canon et en rouge un petit
peu tropique cocktail sirop et compagnie
moi j'ai une vraie préférence pour le
verre et le graphite dites moi lequel
vous préférez en bas dans les
commentaires est-ce qu'il y en a un qui
pourrait vous tenter d'ailleurs est-ce
que vous êtes déjà laissé tenter marquez
moi ça bien évidemment dans les
commentaires